oh
this is actually the first time we try
this robot without any backup support
cranes mechanical mechanisms no cables
nothing ready let's go
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we'll show you some videos now of the
robot doing a bunch of other things we
wanted to show a little bit more what
we've done over the past few months with
about and just walking around and
dancing on stage
just humble beginnings but you can see
the autopilot neural networks running as
is just retrained for the bud uh
directly on that on that new platform
that's my watering can yeah when you
when you see a rendered view that's
that's the robot what's the that's the
world the robot sees so it's it's very
clearly identifying objects like this is
the object it should pick up picking it
up
um yeah
we use the same process as we did for
autopilot to connect data in train your
networks that we didn't Deploy on the
robot that's an example that illustrates
the upper body a little bit more
that will like try to nail down in a few
months over the next few months I would
say to Perfection and we actually have
an Optimus bot with a fully Tesla
designed and both actuators battery pack
uh control system everything
um it it wasn't quite ready to walk uh
but I think it will walk in a few weeks
but we wanted to show you the robot uh
the the something that's actually fairly
close to what will go into production
and
um and show you all the things it can do
so let's bring it out
let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
all right
laughs
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
that we expect to have in Optimus
production unit one which is the ability
to move all the fingers independently
move the to have the thumb have two
degrees of freedom so it has opposable
thumbs and uh both left and right hand
so it's able to operate tools and do
useful things our goal is to make a a
useful humanoid robot as quickly as
possible and we've also designed it
using the same discipline that we use in
designing the car which is to say to
design it for manufacturing such that
it's possible to make the robot at in
high volume at low cost with high
reliability
so that's incredibly important I mean
you've all seen very impressive humanoid
robot demonstrations
um and that that's great but what are
they missing
um they're missing a brain they don't
have the intelligence to navigate the
world uh by themselves and they're
they're also very expensive
um and made in low volume whereas uh
this this is the optimistic society and
extremely capable robot but made in very
high volume probably ultimately millions
of units
um and it is expected to cost much less
than a car
uh I would say probably less than twenty
thousand dollars would be my guess
okay so last year we unveiled the Tesla
bot concept but a concept doesn't get us
very far we knew we needed a real
development and integration platform to
get real-life learnings as quickly as
possible so that robot that came out and
did the little routine for you guys we
had that within six months built working
on software integration Hardware
upgrades over the months since then but
in parallel we've also been designing
the Next Generation this one over here
so this guy is rooted in the the
foundation of sort of the vehicle design
process you know we're leveraging all of
those learnings that we already have so
for example our computer vision neural
networks
um reported directly from autopilot to
the Bots situation
it's exactly the same occupancy Network
that we're talking to a little bit more
details later with the yellow pilot team
that is now running on the butt here in
this video I think the first thing
within the next few weeks is to get
Optimus at least at par with Bumble C
the other bug prototype you saw earlier
and probably Beyond we're also going to
start focusing on the real use case at
one of our factories and really gonna
try to try to nail this down and I run
out all the elements needed to deploy
this product in the real world